one of the largest floods in human
history might have started a
civilization it begins with an earth
4,000 years ago in what is now China
when the quake strikes it sets off on
landslides stopping up a Yellow River
Gorge with a wide pile of rocky debris
at the same time the earthquake causes
the collapse of a downstream village
killing some 20 villagers but leaving
this bowl of noodles unscathed back at
the Yellow River Gorge water begins to
pile up behind the landslide Dam an
enormous link forms over the course of a
few months when water starts flowing
over the top of a makeshift dam it
quickly gives way sending a flood racing
hundreds of kilometers downstream
scouring the gorge and riverbed and
feeling the earthquake fissures around
the lodge oscillating with sediment the
sediment deposits reveal that the
earthquake and the flood happened the
same year scientists were then able to
radiocarbon date the remains of the
villagers to around 1900 BCE this is
where the founding of a civilization
park comes in the first Chinese dynasty
the Shot dynasty was once known as the
legendary dynasty the only evidence that
it existed came from historic texts
written 500 years after the fact what we
know from those writings is that the
shona dynasty started with a giant flood
if the Shah did exist and that's always
been a big if the problem is dating it
according to the history books China's
first dynasty was started around 20 70
BC and was led by Emperor you who earned
the heavenly mandate to rule after
spending decades controlling flood
waters the problem is there's been no
archaeological evidence to support that
story until now
the legendary floodwaters controlled by
you could have been from this very real
outburst flood on the Yellow River
what's more this new date for the flood
lines up neatly with the transition from
Neolithic to the Bronze Age culture in
ancient China if the researchers are
correct that means the trigger for this
massive cultural transformation and the
start of the Shah Dynasty was an extreme
natural event